okay we are live
here there's a lot of stuff to do
there's a lot a lot of stuff to do
um the whole afternoon is going to be
spent on robotic
stuff I have a few different things I
could do right
now I think the most likely
thing the most likely thing that we need
to work on right
now is going to be cleaning up just the
the oblations for the hyper pram sweep
stuff so I can get that merged
in plus it's like we need to make
progress on the hyper Prem sweep stuff
regardless of everything else going on
like there needs to always be some time
to work on uh puffer research
core so we will do that for the next
couple hours
is there some reason
why of all the space in a big
room the Gat always decides to fly right
in front of your
it we're going to figure out what was
wrong with these graphs we had very very
nice graphs before and we have to see
what happened with them
and be a little less focused on
explaining things so I will answer
questions
because yeah there's just a lot of work
to be done this
week I took a little time off
yesterday well more than a little time
off I took most of yesterday off
um just because it was getting to the
point where my productivity was just
dropping it's like I'd rather have the
ability to focus for the week you just
need to take your mind off things for a
little
hold
on did I just this looks fine right
right I'm trying to figure out what was
the result that I had
originally and uh if we have this
reproduced or not
actually wait that's a good
point why was it fitting a
line yeah so this is what you expecting
though this is
not something very very weird here hang
on
this then it did this one
linear unlog I
mean okay so here you have this one
right
yeah see so this one is
actually pretty good I think
1.6 what we say at
45 1.5 at
46 or 1.6 of yeah so this is on
par this is pretty well on
par like this is a very nice nice curve
right here
right these are the earlier
points so I think that this is pretty
good do we not get this when we go back
so
10 oh it was on linear before so that
wasn't the
issue okay so we have this one here
right
funny okay so we can see there is what
appears to be a quite substantial
difference in perf between these two
right
can you paste in a uh a fork I mean a
commit ID commit has
UI you have to change the url that's so
stupid
okay uh
so between these
two let's let's not roll these changes
out cuz this actually could be it right
here
um in fact that's super easy to test so
let's do
that's
it
run and in the meantime we will
look oh hold on did I miss
one no I didn't miss one good
this isn't even bad if you look at it
it's just um
same I don't know if I forgot to commit
this file back then or what
here maybe I handled this wrong hang on
global search scale
weird I don't trust this diff thing
either cuz this looks weird to me
something's
okay here's the global search scale term
right
really that seems very
odd me we'll try it
I mean it would be
um was it 0.5 time
this CU it be time * 5 and then 0.1 *
this it would be very weird if that
worked
earth oh you see you have these random
samples all the way out
here hang
on I bet you it's I bet you it's just
worse going be back in a few minutes um
I'm trying to think though
I'm going to be I'm going to think about
this I'll be right
changes what are all the other little
tweaks I've made let me
okay so you do actually get a little bit
out of those extra points
else let me double check something
would it be the total time step somehow
no this is
identical hey welcome we're doing a
little bit of hyper pram stuff because I
want to merge some of this up for
uh collaborator of mine to use
um and then we're going to be doing
robotic stuff for the majority of today
in a couple hours once kyung wakes
up he's on West
Coast took a little time off yesterday
so it wasn't live and it was just
getting to the point where my brain was
just like skipping 30 second increments
while I was working so usually that
tells me it's time to take your day
off at a good
time that's
yeah know this is all identical okay so
it's got to be then in in the rest of
it I forget were you working on an
enany I thought you had some stuff you
were working on or is that someone
you should at least go take your easy
five on all those exams like you will
screw yourself over if you don't but uh
for a long term yeah it's not it's not
how you
yeah this was flipped
normal first time viewer here hello I
know almost nothing about machine
learning or RL in general but I'm quite
interested so yeah welcome if you do
have a programming
background I have a quick start
guide that is way less mathy than most
of the stuff out there it's a kind of
like a get into RL over a weekend kind
of a thing
I'll put this in the
chat um yeah it just gives sort of my
perspective on a lot of stuff and a
short list like an actually pretty short
list of good
resources like the open AI spinning up
one is pretty good but uh it's like way
more math and algorithms than you
actually need and nowhere near enough
engineering so this is my take on it
oh
welcome that's so funny you just
have people sick of
their crappy high school computer
science
jeez yeah I think that um generally the
best thing that newer is programmers can
do and I you can have been program for a
few years but without like any formal
instruction is to just go do uh
stamford's like cs106x maybe they're
better courses that's the one I took cuz
I went to Stanford for undergrad so
that's pretty good uh don't necessarily
listen to them on code style or anything
like that but just for core algorithms
and data structures and such it was
pretty good um I it sucks that it's
taught in
C++ cuz it's just a pain but no know
it's it's
okay I mean C++ is kind of an okay
language to
teach I guess it's
okay because the thing is you need
pointers um you do need pointers but
it's also like you would like to have
other data structures built in so that
you don't like that your lesson is
focused on the data structure that
you're covering so I kind of get
it I honestly think it would have been
probably easier in C but
um you know they don't want to have to
teach you like stack in Heap in memory
management so I kind of get
it for the RL stuff my guide should be
pretty decent to especially it's like
it's less math than you're going to need
anywhere else and uh the math takes a
while to
get
abysmal okay so
here we already have the scores
transformed oops I think that this was
this same algorithm as I have now it's
just for some reason I broke it
somewhere let me see
so set data so it's training on
normalized scores so normaliz is after
transformed
right dang
it what's going on here is I have this
really awesome hyper pram sweep
algorithm but I when I went to clean it
up I somehow broke some stuff so I have
to fix this mess that I've
made
um like you see I like I cleaned up all
the variable names and
stuff I mean it's more than just that
otherwise that would be pretty easy to
catch let me just go line by line here
to make sure at least this portion is
the same
so raw scores which is
y yeah so raw scores is
y mean Max Max mean standard
deviation okay and then we have
transform squares which I'm calling YT
now negative
log y over Max Plus F this is
good then you take mean standard
deviation
you
Norm okay and then Min YT Norm
Norm yeah so this is the same and then
that function just gives you YT Norm so
that should be
fine and then what do you do with it you
set data to Norm
which
is
here train mode you train
it eval yeah this is all
fine and next we get costs which are
here we get log
costs we get Max log cost
here okay and this is where something
weird
happened so I
do minus Min IDE maxus Min and then I
multiply by maxus Min so this cancels
and then I add the Min so these lines
are completely redundant
right unless I use log
cost hold on do I use this somewhere
else
no so yeah this was completely redundant
I don't know how I even did that that's
ridiculous
um
okay we want the highest cost one which
is just max
here and then the mean
function gives you log C Max okay
wait did I not set
the yeah okay cu the mean score is
allowed to be zero okay this is
fine
um normalize log cost it's going to be
log
C rain and eal
so this is all the same this is
identical so
far predict and
score where is it oh no we have to do
sample first so you sample get Pito
points search
centers sample normal which is the
original sample that I had
this is the same this 0.1 is fine
because it's I made it 10x larger up top
adjustment per
Pito number of candidates a little
different but we adjusted that already
and then you flip
fine and then you just predict both of
these score
cost on
wait a
second how's this
so uh this works because the suggestion
is already in the same latent space
so we do all these Transformations we
maintain whatever the suggestion is in
that same
space and then um yeah so then we fit
the model to the to that we're
good so now what we have so this is Norm
for me so we do the
GP YT norm and then YT V and then we
have log cost and log cost variance
anybody working on a Flappy Bird M
actually I think somebody just did one
of
those I think you missed doing that by
like a
week who is it yeah Louis Valero here
has a million step per second Flappy
RL I have not seen his code yet so we
will see how that looks
okay so this is a a prime spot for error
potentially so log cost standard
deviation as you take
this you subtract the Min log
cost you divide by this term and then
you multiply by this
term okay so this is weird but it does
nothing log cost
SD s let me just make
conservative so we'll have to check and
make sure we're not using these
conservative numbers
anywhere but
okay so GPC is you just take X
right and
I don't know if this one is as good
because this one is a purely mechanical
game
man like literally the whole difficulty
of the game is the block moving too fast
so like I think it would be pretty
boring to watch cuz it's just going to
be the same exact action I mean it's
literally like there's one state that
you have to map to the action and that's
it
good did anybody ever figure out if
those machines were rigged or Not by the
way cuz those were always the machines
that they had their really big prizes
attached to like uh you could win like a
game console or whatever from those so I
assume that they were probably rigged
yeah but I mean like rigged in the sense
of literally like you push the button in
the right spot and it just fails It
Anyways like that's like blatant right
there's stuff like the uh like the
basketball hoops where they make the uh
the hoop like they stretch the hoop a
little bit so like you basically can't
get the you can't make a basket if you
bounce it off the backboard you have to
just hit it straight on like that's one
thing
or like the uh like throw a ball at
three stacked blocks like those are just
deceptive
right it's not actually like failing you
behind the
scenes I don't even know if they still
have carnivals like that to be honest
thing normalize
parito what happened to
this I think I have him just out of
order so okay so
parito normalize parito course
well wait here you have PR y PR YT and
Pito
C
okay and then what do I do I do cost
C so GPC minus
prto which
no these are
correct Donkey
Kong yeah like any of the I always tell
people like any of the old arcade games
are great little toy tasks to have um if
you're looking for something like of
middle complexity like any of the old
arcade games will be good I think Donkey
Kong there might be IP behind um
like
there's I know I tried asteroids a while
ago like that's a decent one Space
Invaders they're all sorts of ones that
can be done
um I mean it's like there are a couple
things here right I kind of just keep
giving these out to people as projects
for like newer people or like new to Mid
like middle experienc people cuz like
they're useful more arcade games are
good just to have more of them um we do
learn stuff from
those so I think like yeah any of those
are fine I think actually you know what
would be the most useful though the
original Seven Atari games there were
seven Atari games that were used by the
original dqn
paper and eventually I would like to
have all seven of
where is it beam Rider breakout and duro
pong cubert sequest in space invader so
we have three of these right we have
breakout and duro and pong
D so these are the remaining
ones um I would suggest that you submit
something a little bit more toy to me
first just cuz I know you're a newer
programmer and some of these could end
up being more complex than uh I
anticipate like the thing with some of
these is I expect that most of these
would take me a day or two but I could
be wrong and they could be more complex
than anticipated and they could take me
a week
right with any of these
if they take me more than a week then I
guess I've just screwed up massively but
I would doubt
it yeah I would just do something like
that just Port some like simple little
thing to see so I can look at the code
and that'll save you some
time okay so cost diff is correct and
then cost distance
is the absolute
value distance to nearest
parito Min cost distance diff Min of
cost
distance so I have nearest I've got both
of
cost
difference less than zero gets set to
here yeah so this is the this is
probably the difference right here um
that was a legitimate difference let me
explain what I
did so the way that this algorithm
works the way that this algorithm
works you have why is it do
that you have points on a curve like
let's say whoops
you have points on a curve like this
is and uh what if you're going to put a
new point in here like let's say you put
a point here then the algorithm looks
at this performance increase over the
nearest point and then it looks at this
distance between
points so by mistake instead of taking
this distance I also took this distance
which would give you negative values
which is
wrong uh let's see if that actually
changes anything or if it's still
broken because it very well could just
still be broken here and it looks like
it
is yeah that's actually more broken
interesting let's see why that is
here this is
interesting we just put a break
um now we already have sample normal
huh we literally should have the same
thing then
um okay what I can do is I can go check
the magnitudes
yep so you can see that this one is way
better right
visualize did hang on did I just not
visualized
yeah because we were getting the I yeah
this is definitely
wrong okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to go here
yeah so it is normal for this to be a
very small
value
um o this one is way bigger the distance
to nearest Paro
right yeah yeah yeah look at this so we
have so was in the candidate process
yeah let me see so these initial points
go up to like 18 and 20 hold
on or even 40
sometimes then my initial points
off yeah yeah hold on we are training
with h we have completely different seed
data
here I don't know why this would make a
difference let's
see yeah no you can see that the cost is
so much lower here
10 parameters
here
73 so you got there's a0 2 here and then
4524 oh okay so there's just the
addition of a0 2 in here
somehow there's one extra
anything as well go see what it is
though
mini B
size seem
right bches ah mini badge size
yeah I wonder if that actually changes
on anything
that actually might I think I have that
in the formula don't
no okay we still have low
costs I think that six is the
outlier oh we're getting six is
I so aside from that and
one we get these
five yeah so this is
all all the same and then it's 25 was 25
at the end yeah
oh wait did I change the
task I might have changed the
task that'd be a stupid thing
thought I changed something here didn't
I
okay I hate to do this
but we've wasted enough time
and I'm going to have to be done with
this in an hour so we're just going to
do it the stupid
way I can guarantee that this will work
I should have just started with this I
guess but it's so so rare that I break
things this badly that I have to do
things like
this
um but this will guaranteed
just going to make sure that I didn't
break anything with this
that's the same thing we just got this
point way out
hold
on I might have just found it and save
myself a bunch of
time let me
it's just very weird because it would
seem like this is not
um it would seem like this is not an
issue with that
I'm just seeing if it's basically if the
error
is even in here at
on maybe I can find one of these samples
from before
yeah very weird because um I mean
these samples look the same everything
looks the
same
nothing's freaking changed in this while
this is for sweeps only this is not for
testing
I don't
know yep that is weird
this I actually don't know what I could
have screwed up here it's a crazy thing
right oh yeah there we go so this is
this fix needed to be in there at the
very
interesting it's not trying to push
farther
away for
so this gives you this
nice log curve
is there a reason to do the score in um
log space like
this I thought I had a cool transform
here yeah yeah there is it's not log
space it's uh it's a better trans more
than that so
YT multiply by standard deviation add
the mean
times so these are all expecting to
score less
than
huh okay wait did we find something I
think we found something maybe
I'm surprised that doesn't
help it does get the ratings to be a
little
this this is a log curve right it's just
stretched doesn't look very
loggy
this should
work I would think
it just take longer to figure this out
or something
cuz this really should make I mean this
loss should push it towards higher and
higher
cost okay now it has no still doesn't
have a decent cost
okay this is way closer to what we would
expect I don't know why it just wasn't
doing it
before must have been like a save file a
weird
bug uh
okay yeah so here it is jumping too far
and you can see it's got a few misses
so this should prevent it from doing
that we'll
so that makes explore too
slowly very sensitive to that
parameter I think if we did like 60
experiments so 50 runs you would see it
I want to look at that
behavior I mean we have the consistent
like curve now it's just a matter of
getting it to
be cleaner
okay I like these because these are
um actually accurately estimating the
cost I don't know how it jumps from 60
to 174 like
this I'm just be the way that we have
the
uh cost space set
better this is very clean there are a
few misses that we've got
to got to look at here
we have at least a clean curve back so
I'm going to commit this current
okay some stuff to review I really want
to get time to finish this but I've got
a few other things to do today so I'm
going to go get some food
um
before kung is up and I've got to start
on that stuff um for folks in the
meantime if you are generally interested
in the work that I do and are interested
in RL whether you are brand new or an
expert you can follow all this work on
puffer doai want to help me out for free
star thee GitHub really helps it when we
uh when we get starts on the
GitHub oops
this is one of the main progress metrics
that I track to see how well we're doing
here
1603 if you want to get involved join
the Discord discord. GPU you can also
follow me on X for even more RL content
got a Blog with lots of great resources
and some additional articles on X that
you can't find anywhere else thank you
and I'm